[Music]
well my dad had
high blood pressure and he ended up with
two strokes and i did not want that
so you know i was 220 over 110
twice and that really scared me i
decided i better make the commitment or
if i'm gonna i'm gonna live any longer
and
we called the doctor wallach radio show
and he told me to lose weight
and then we went to finally got to a
good doctor here in kansas and he told
me to lose weight
i weighed about 252 when i started in
the ending i
was well i'm not ended yet i'm still
losing i'm down to
207 this morning so that's 45. i didn't
do it for the money i did it for
to get healthy again i was playing
basketball with my
grandson he finagled me into it but i
didn't i didn't really want to play but
he talked me into it
and uh we had played on eight eight foot
baskets where i don't know
but i could dunk the ball in eight foot
basket i couldn't do it before i lost
the weight
i'm a turkey hunter wild turkey's
weighed average of 20 to 24 pounds
what i got rid of was carrying two wild
turkeys around all the time
i haven't tried it on yet but i think my
army uniform which i got out of the army
in 1968
i think it'll fit me again i have to
change my lifestyle to lose weight and
i'm about to keep that lifestyle
to keep from getting it back